best piece of advice that my therapist
taught me that i now share with my
clients as a therapist to improve any
relationship here it is whatever the
conversation is and whoever it is with i
want you to make sure that you are
actively listening instead of just
waiting for your turn to talk so many
times we get so excited that we just
want to say what we have to say without
even listening to that other person
especially if it's a debate or an
argument and we think we're right and we
just want to aggressively go in there
and say our point but that is not
healthy and not what we want to do what
we want to do is engage in active
listening which is listening with the
intent to understand the way the other
person is feeling this will help us
develop empathy towards that person even
if we don't agree with them empathetic
active listening is proven to help
improve healthy communication and to
help lead to a quicker solution so the
next time you're in a conversation with
somebody i want you to ask am i actively
listening or am i just waiting for my
turn to speak if you're just waiting try
to understand how that person's feeling